احييكم مشاهدينا طبعا هذه التغطيه على
العربيه ما زالت مستمره لكل التطورات
الحاصله في السودان اظهر مقطع فيديو تم
تداوله عبر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
تحديدا امام احد المستشفيات في مروي قرب
المطار عمليه اسر لقوات من الدعم السريع
نتابع ومن ثم نكون مع زملائنا المراسلين
ومع ضيوفنا ايضا حتى نطلع اكثر على كل
التطورات الحاصله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قال رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي في
السودان الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان في
تصريحاته للعربيه ان المتمردين من قوات
دعم للسيطره على مقرات الجيش والمناطق
الحيويه فجرا واضاف البرهان ان متمردي
الدعم السريع خططوا لتنفيذ اغتيالاته وان
خيار الجيش الوحيد هو تصدي لمطامع من
وصفهم بالمتمردين في السلطه كما قال عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان الجيش يدير عمليات ضد
المتمردين بصبر لمنع وقوع اي خسائر بشريه
واكد ان الجيش السوداني لديه قوات كافيه
واراده لدحر هؤلاء الاشخاص
وهذه الاخبار العاجله وبعض المواقف التي
تاتي طبعا بخصوص هذه التطورات في السودان
رئيس الحزب التحالف الوطني السوداني
العربيه يقول هناك معارك تجري حاليا في
الخرطوم وان هناك ضحايا سقطت اذا حسب رئيس
حزب التحالف الوطني السوداني العربيه بانه
هناك اشتباكات وهناك وقوع لضحايا كما قال
ايضا ان الاتفاق الايطالي هو الحل للخروج
من هذه الازمه الحاليه لمتابعه التطورات
على الارض من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك معنا
الصوره لديك
وماذا يجري الان في الخرطوم هل الاشتباكات
ما زالت مستمره واين تتركز
مسرحا كبيرا لمناورات عسكريه ضخمه جدا
9:00 صباحا وحتى هذه اللحظه ما زلنا نسمع
دويا الانفجارات في كل الاماكن المتفرقه
الجديد انه تتزايد اعداد الضحايا في على
كل راس ساعه
تتجدد هذه الاعداد وهناك تحديث لاعداد
الضحايا نتحدث عن ضحايا المدنيين الان
ما زلنا نشهد ازدياد لهذه الاعداد خاصه في
في مناطق ومثليه بالكامل للاسف غالب هذه
القليل من هذه الاشتباسات لذلك وجدنا فيه
الان ثلاث مستشفيات وجدنا فيها اعداد من
الضحايا يتوافدوني الى هذه المستشفيات
سالم هناك جرحك كيف هو وضعهم
هناك حالات حرجه حتى حينما وصلنا المستشفى
كانت الحاله الحرجه واحده وقد توفيت قبل
ساعتين من الان عدد الوفيات ايضا تجاوز
العشرات الان هذه الاعداد هذا الوضع
الماساوي حقيقه القوى الملفت في هذه
اللحظه
ادعوا للقلق
والوضع الانساني اولا ثانيا الان
المواطنين يعاني من كثير من الامور ابرزها
هذا الذعر الذي يعيش فيه المواطنين وانا
اقول كل المواطنين حتى خارج السودان التي
تاتي وغيرها كل مواطن سوداني الان هو في
حاله من الذعر مما يحدث لانه لا يعلم ما
الذي سيحدث بعد دقيقه او دقيقه من هذه
الاشتباكات الغير هناك انباء متضاربه
الجيش السوداني يقول بانه سيطر على بعض
المناطق وبعض المواقع ودعم السريع يتحدث
بانه بدوره ايضا سيطر على بعض المناطق ما
هي المعلومات حول ذلك هل هناك من سيطره
لطرف اكثر من طرف اخر
نعم يصعب حسم هذه القضيه بهذه الدقه لكن
دعينا نقول ان هناك مناطق فبكل تاكيد بنفق
بان قوات الدعم السريع سيطرت عليها
بانباء مؤكده ومصادر مؤكده من خمس مبدا
الاذاعه والتلفزيون
بالكامل هذه من الانباء المؤكده وهل يعمل
التلفزيون الان سالم ام لا
هل يبث التلفزيون التلفزيون الان يبث مواد
قديمه فقط موجود في التلفزيون الان فني
البث وتم ضرب الاستوديو الرئيسي للاخبار
فنيول بث موجودون الان لا يستطيعون الخروج
من التلفزيون وذكروا لنا بانه تم الاعتذار
لهم من قبل هذه القوات قوات الدعم السريع
بانهم اجبروا على فعل هذا الامر وانهم ليس
لديهم اعداء مع احد وذكروا بانهم لم يعتدي
عليهم احد ولم تكن هناك اي اصابات في داخل
ضمن الاذاعه والتلفزيون حتى هذه اللحظه
ماذا عن المطار
المطار المطار الخرطوم الدولي في البدايه
ذكرت الدعم السريع انها تسيطر عليه الجيش
السوداني واكد بانه يسيطر على المطار انه
تم انزال مظاليم في داخل المطار تتضارب
الانباء لكن حدود المطار والمنطقه المحيطه
بالمقر المنطقه الحاويه الحيويه في
الخرطوم تصاعد منها الويه الدخان كثيف
ويسمع فيها ذوي انفجار في الاربع ساعات
الماضيه لا يستطيع احد الاقتراب منها حتى
يتاكد فقط من ذلك تم اجلاع عدد من
الموجودين في داخل مطار الخرطوم من
المواطنين كان هناك عدد من المسافرين في
داخل مطار الخرطوم انباع اصابات بعضهم
خاصه فيما يتعلق بالضرب بالضربه التي حصلت
للطيران في داخل مطار الخرطوم وقد تضررت
الطائره سعوديه تتبع الخطوط الجويه
السعوديه في داخل مطار الخرطوم اليوم هذا
هذا المطر غيره ايضا مثل مطار مروي اكدت
قوات الدعم الشريعه انها تسيطر عليه اكدت
انها تسيطر على القاعده الجويه الانباء عن
سيطرتها على واحده من الالويه المتعلقه
بالمدرعات التابعه للجيش السوداني انها
تسيطر على مطار الابيض ايضا حتى هذه من
الانباء المتداوله التي تقولها قوات الدعم
السريع لكن على الارض نقول انه لا تتضح
الرؤيه لان الحركه شبه مشلوله تماما نحن
الان نعاني في الحركه القريبه بمجرد ان
تتحرك
اصوات الاعياد الناريه لا توجد حركه
مواصلات لا يوجد مواطنين الان في الشارع
في الصباح كان هناك من التحليق لطيران
الجيش السوداني وكان هناك انباء تحدثت عن
مضادات استخدمتها او استخدمها الدعم
السريع الان ما هي طبيعه الاشتباكات انواع
الاسلحه هل هي اسلحه ثقيله هل هي اسلحه
متوسطه خفيفه
الان عفوا في الساعه الماضيه الساعه
الماضيه بدات تنحسر مساله عمليه الطيران
ومشاركه الطيران في هذه العمليات فقط اصبح
دويه الانفجارات وكذلك
اصواتها الناريه المتفرقه بين الفين
والاخرى تسمع في اتجاهات متفرقه من
العاصمه لكن غالب هذه الاصوات تصدر من
المنطقه المركزيه في محيط القصر الجمهوري
ومحيط القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
وايضا المنطقه المحاطه بهذه ومطار الخرطوم
كل هذه المناطق الحيويه المتقاربه جدا في
قلب العاصمه الخرطوم
دائما ابقى معنا سالم
سنعود اليك من الخرطوم ولكن ايضا سنتابع
مع بعض التطورات وبعض الاخبار مع ضيفنا
طاهر المعتصم الكاتب الصحفيه طاهر انت
ايضا متواجد في الخرطوم حتى الان ليس هناك
من صوره واضحه عما يسيطر في بعض الاماكن
وفي بعض المواقع ولكن هذه الاشتباكات ما
زالت مستمره من اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن
مشاعر هل من مساء جديه من الممكن ان تخفف
وتهدئ الاوضاع
من الصعوبه بما كانت تكرههم يعني يمكن
احداث اختراق عبر مسائي لتغريد وجهات
النظر او على الاقل
لوقف اطلاق النار
ماذا لحتى اللحظه ذوي اطلاق النار في
مناطق متعدده من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم يسمع ما زالت الشوارع خاويه ما
زالت بعض لجان المجتمعيه في الاحياء تحاول
ان تؤمن المساكن والاحياء ومناطق محطات
المياه والكهرباء وغيرها
مازال الوضع في غايه الصعوبه الجسور التي
تربط العاصمه الخرطبي كما تعلمي سيدتي ان
الخرطوم عباره عن ثلاثه مدن بينهم
الان وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يتحدث بل
ويدعو الاشقاء في السودان لسرعه وقف
العمليات العسكريه وضبط النفس اذا
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يدعو الاشقاء في
السودان لسرعه وقف العمليات العسكريه
وضبط النفس
هناك ايضا ايضا هناك مواقف اخرى لوزير
الخارجيه السعوديه حيث قال على الاشقاء في
السودان تجنب التصعيد وتغريب مصلحه شعبهم
هذه الاخبار العاجله على لسان وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الذي قال بان على اشقاء
في السودان تجنب التصعيد وتغليب مصلحه
شعبهم والعوده الى الاتفاق الايطالي اعود
اليك طاهر طبعا هناك دعوات كثيره من مختلف
الدول الاقليميه وايضا من المجتمع الدولي
لتخفيف هذا الاحتقان ولضبط النفس ولكن على
الارض الامور ما زالت ايله للتصعيد حسب ما
تتابعون
وتوقع انه
قليلا في الساعه القادمه
بحسب مشاهداتنا ومت
[موسيقى]
السودان وليس الخرطوم فقط سيدتي بل عدد من
مدن السودان الان هي تعاني من هذا
ابقى معي ايضا وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
ادعوا السودانيين الى العوده للحوار
لتحقيق الامن والاستقرار للبلاد نعود
ونذكر بمعظم ما جاء على لسان وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه حيث دعى السودانيين الى
العوده للحوار لتحقيق الامن والاستقرار
للبلاد كما دعا الاطراف السودانيه العوده
للاتفاق الايطالي للتوصل لحل سياسي وقال
بانه على الاشقاء في السودان تجنب التصعيد
وتغليب مصلحه شعبهم كما ذكر بل دعا وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الاشقاء في السودان
لسرعه وقف العمليات العسكريه وضبط النفس
نتابع ايضا مشاهدينا ما اعربت عنه وطبعا
الخارجيه السعوديه حيث تابعنا منذ قليل
على لسان وزير الخارجيه حيث اعربت ايضا
الخارجيه عن قلق المملكه من حاله التصعيد
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في السودان
كما دعت السعوديه المكونه العسكري وجميع
القيادات السياسيه في السودان الى تغريب
لغه الحوار وضبط النفس والتواصل لاعلان
سياسي يتحقق بموجبه الاستقرار
ايضا سفاره المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم دعت كافه
المواطنين المقيمين في السودان الى البقاء
في منازلهم والتواصل مع سفاره السعوديه في
الخرطوم على رقم الطوارئ الخاص بالمواطنين
في حال الضروره
قبل ان نتابع ايضا تشاد تعلن اغلاق الحدود
مع السودان حتى اشعار اخر اذا تشاد اعلنت
اغلاق الحدود مع السودان حتى اشعار اخر
مصر ايضا اعربت عن بالقلقها ايذاء
الاشتباكات الدائره بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في السودان ودعت كافه الاطراف
السودانيه الى ممارسه اقصى درجات ضبط
النفس حمايه لارواحي ومقدرات الشعب
السوداني واعلاء المصالح العليا للوطن
هذا ويتواصل لا مسؤولون مصريون مع اطراف
سودانيه لوقف المعارك الحاليه في ظل
مبادره مصريه لتخفيف الاجواء والاحتقان
ووفق مصادر خاصه للعربيه طالبت القاهره
بوقف اطلاق النار الغير مشروط بين الاطراف
السودانيه حيث تتواصل مع عدد من المسؤولين
في السودان للتوصل الى صيغه لوقف اطلاق
النار والعوده الى المفاوضات المشتركه كما
طالبت القاهره بضروره تجنب استهداف
المدنيين ووقف التصعيد الحالي
بعض المواطنين
يحاولون ان يلوذوا بالفرار وكما تتابع
الان عبر هذه الصور الحصريه المصاحبه بصوت
اطلاق النار يذهبون الى داخل المدينه
لاهلهم نعم لاهلهم الى ذويهم يحاولون ان
يحتموا بكل ما من شانه ان يوفر الامن
والسلام والاستقرار
ايضا قبل ان انتقل الى ضيفي من الخرطوم
دكتور كمال عمر الامين السياسي لحزب
المؤتمر الشعبي وعضو اللجنه التنسيقيه
للحوار الايطالي ايضا هناك موقف لامين عام
الامم المتحده الذي يدين هذه الاشتباكات
الحاصله بين السودانيين اذا امين عام
الامم المتحده يدين الاشتباكات بين
السودانيين كما تدعو الامم المتحده لوقف
الاشتباكات بين السودانيين استاذ كمال
اهلا بك معنا هناك مطالبات ان كان داخليه
كان من قبل رئيس الوزراء السودانيه السابق
ايضا رؤساء احزاب هناك ايضا مطالبات من
دول عربيه من دول اقليميه الان الامم
المتحده ايضا تدعو الى ضبط النفس بالاضافه
الى الولايات المتحده ايضا على اللسان
وزير خارجيتها كان دعا الى ضبط النفس
وانما يجري في السودان هو مقلق هذا المشهد
الذي نحن امامه اليوم لماذا وصل الى هذا
الحد
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[موسيقى]
تحيه لكم في قناه العربيه
الشعب السوداني والسياسيه كلها ممتنه
للدور التي
ظل الذي ظل يلعبه الاعلام خاصه قناه
العربيه
الفتيه المحترمه يعني الحاله
التي وصلت
اليها الحاله السياسيه السودانيه نحن قلنا
متوقعين الذي يحدث
لانه نظام السابق ترك تركه ثقيله من من
المشاكل المتعلقه ببنيه الدوله السودانيه
في المؤسسات
كل المؤسسات بالذات المؤسسه العسكريه
لذلك
نظام السابق تركها منذ فتره طبعا لها ذيول
ولكن هذه الفتره منذ سقوط البشير حتى الان
الم تكن كافيه لملممه الاوضاع السودانيه
ان كان الامنيه العسكريه السياسيه لان
البعض يعتبر بان هذا الخلاف اليوم بين
العسكريين هو خلاف سياسي وليس عسكري هو
خلاف مصالح هو خلاف على من سيكون في
السلطه ومن سيقود المشهد الامني والعسكري
بعد
انتخاب او بعد تشكيل اي حكومه مدنيه
انت لو صبرتي لو صبرت انا بوصل لنتائج لكن
لا باس يعني
الخلاف الخلافه الان الذي ادى الى الحرب
خلاف سياسي بعدين
العسكر لا يعرفون لغه انا لغه
اللغه السلميه العسكر عندما يختلفوا
ويستعملون الاسلحه في خلافاتهم ونحن ظلينا
ظلينا نرقد هذا المشهد حتى الامس حتى
الامس ظلت مجهودات القوى السياسيه في
تهدئه الامور في نزع فتيل الازمه في
التوافق السياسي ظلينا مؤمنين بالخط
السياسي بالعمليه السياسيه الحاليه لكن
الذي حدث اليوم حاجه يعني حاجه مؤسفه
للغايه الم
تكن كمال يعني من يتابع المشهد وخاصه في
الاسابيع الماضيه كان يتوقع بانه ما يحصل
هو
سيؤدي الى هذه المواجهه
بالبنادق وبالاسلحه بين هذه الاطراف
العسكريه لماذا لم يتم احتواء الامر قبل
وقوع هذا التصعيد
خارق في احتواء الامر
كقوه سياسيه موقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي
بزنها هو هناك قوه اخرى في الكتله
الديمقراطيه
بذلت جهدي خارج لاحتواء الازمه لكن ازمه
السلطه ازمه
الانفراض بالسلطه بازمه يعني في محيطنا
الافريقي والعربي دائما السلطه هذه السبب
اساسي
لاسقاق الارواح احنا ما بنعرف وسيله لما
نختلف
سياسيا
غير الاحتراب
والحروب
الان هو التهدئه من قادر هل هناك اي طرف
داخل السودان قادر هل هناك اطراف خارجيه
قادره على التدخل حتى لا تطول الامور
هناك مجهودات مجهودات في الداخلي تتبناها
تنظيمات سياسيه نتبع لها وهناك مجهودات
خارقه لقوى عربيه
للدول العربيه الان في شان هناك مجهودات
دوليه يعني احنا نامل ونتمنى نتمنى من هذه
الجهه
الاقليمي وجهه الوطني والجهد العالمي يعني
يؤدي الى وقت القتال لانه القتال ده
الفائز فيه والغالب فيه مهزوم لانه الغالب
فيه الغالب فيه يعني حيغلب على اداء الشعب
السوداني حيغلبان الشعب السوداني على
ارواحه على ممتلكاته الطرف الثاني المهزوم
المهزوم المهزوم طرف سوداني ما طرف اجنبي
ان تبقى معي لاذهب مجددا الى ضيفنا طاهر
المعتصم الكاتب الصحفي من يتحمل مسؤوليه
هذا التصعيد اليوم
المكون العسكري شيخي
قائد الجيش و قائد الدعم السريع لان
الامور بينهما الى هاويه صعبه جدا
بين الشخصين ام بين
المؤسستين يعني اذا اردنا ان نتحدث كدعم
السريع مؤسسه وايضا الجيش الوطني
مؤكد ما بين الدعم السريع وما بين الجيش
ولكن رياضه الطرفين هي التي تتحمل
المسؤوليه كان يمكنهم نزع فتيل الازمه
كما تحدث ضيفك الكريم
القوه السياسيه والقوه الرقابيه والمجتمع
المدني في الخرطوم وفي السودان على مدى
الايام السابقه حاول ان يطلع عدد من
المبادرات بنزع شتيل
الازمه والتي تمظهرت اكثر ما يكون في ان
الدعم السريع تحرك الى منطقه مروي في شمال
السودان ثم التبادل البيانات بين الطرفين
بين الجيش والدعم السريع
وما صدر فيها من اتهامات كانت مؤشرات
واضحه
لجميع هنا ان الامور لن تذهب في الطريق
الصحيح وان هناك مجموعات
تراهن على ان الفوضى
يمكنها ان تصنع لها مساحه للحركه والظهور
يعني
حديثك بانه الطرفان يريدان هذه الفوضى حتى
لا يتم تطبيق الاتفاق الاطاري
يدعى قبل قليل تحدث وادعى انه مع الاتفاق
الايطالي وغيره ولكن
[موسيقى]
ذهابهم في الاتفاق الاطار ايضا وخروج من
السلطه يعني قائد الجيش السوداني يعلم
منذ من العام الم
اضي خروجهم من العمليه السي
اسيه ولكن على ارض الواقع هم مستمرين على
ارض الواقع جعلوا العقده في مساله الاصلاح
الامني وهو اخر ملف واخر مؤتمر في الملفات
الخاصه بالاتفاق النهائي
بانه كل الحلول التي تعد كترقيع هي ما
اوصلت الامور الى ما اوصلت اليه يعني
لماذا لم يتم الحسم لماذا لم يتم وضع ملف
الامن والعسكر لبعض ما تشكيل الحكومه
طلع كان يمكن وهناك مبادره طلبت هذا الامر
في خلال الايام الماضيه ولكن اعتقد ان
الطرفي الازمه
والجيش تحديدا اراد ان يحسم هذا الامر وان
لا يذهب في الاتفاق الا بحسن امر الدعم
السريع
تكون شبه مزاج عام في الجيش السوداني رافض
لقوات الدعم السريع خلال الفتره الماضيه
طب بالنسبه ايضا
لموضوع العمليه السياسيه البعض يقول بانه
هذا الخلاف الان وهذا التصعيد اليوم هو
نتيجه او تخوفا من اي اتفاق سياسي فهم
يريدون ان يعلموا او ان يحسموا الامور قبل
اي اتفاق سياسي وقبل اي تشكيل اي حكومه
مدنيه هل هذا
التصور او هل هذا الراي هو واقعي
قد يكون واقعي لان الاتفاق السياسي الراهن
العمليه السياسيه يطالب بخروج المؤسسه
العسكريه كامله من الحياه السياسيه
وتمها الاتفاق على هذا الامر في خمسه
ديسمبر من العام الماضي لكن عندما
اقارب الاوان وكاد ان يحدث التوقيع حدث
مقتل العهود والمواسيخ حدث تراجع من
الاطراف
حدث تعجيل وتاجيج وخلال الايام الماضيه
سيدتي هناك كانت اصوات نشاز تعلي من خطاب
الكراهيه تجعل الفتنه ما بين هذه الاصوات
استسلمت
انا انا طاهر
نعم اصوات في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
صفحات منسوبه بعضها للنظام القديم بعضها
لاعلاميين الاعلاميه كبرى صنعت
تمهيد لهذا الواقع الذي حدث اليوم باعلان
خطاب الكراهيه على الفتنه ما بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
بصوره فوق ما تتصوري كل المراقبين كانوا
ينظرون الى هذا الامر
نذهب الى دكتور كمال لنسمع رايه ايضا الى
اي حد دكتور كمال ما زال النظام نظام
البشير مازال قويا الى حد ان يشعل ما تم
اشعاله اليوم اذا كان حقيقه فلول النظام
نظام البشير كما يسمونه هم وراء ما يحصل
اليوم
احييك مره اخرى وهي الاستاذ المحترم
الطاهر طبعا انا متفق مع الطاهره على على
المسببات ولا على الموقف ده طبعا النظام
السابق ده نظام يعني حكم السودان 30 سنه
من الحكومه الشموله المنفرد
وكل الناس كل الشعب السوداني يدرك الان
يعني
دق طبول الحرب
والتشجيع على العرضه من قبل النظام السابق
لانه النظام السابقه لا يريد لا يريد
حكومه ديمقراطيه لا يريد تحكمه مدنيه
المشكله الاساسيه في اندلاع الصراع ده
مشكله تسليم السلطه لحكومه مدنيه نحن
فرقنا من من عدد من الخطوات السياسيه
المهمه وفضل خطوه سياسيه وتوصلنا في اخر
اجتماع قلنا الخطوه الاساسيه بتاعت الد مج
نخليها للسلطه المدنيه القادمه
يعني ده اتفاق لذلك يعني
الحرب اللي نشبت بين الطرفين يعني انا ما
داير احمي الجهه
المسؤوليه لكن هو انا بحمل الجهتين جهتين
مسؤولون ماذا في
لماذا اختاين هذا هذا الخلاف بين دعم
السريع وبين الجيش السوداني ليس وليد
اليوم وانما هو وليد اشهر
وسنوات لماذا اليوم اشعال هذا الفتيل
بالرجوع
للشكل الشكل الدعم السريع وياري الدعم
السريع من الذي اوجد الدعم السريع
عن ايجاد الدعم السريع ده تكون بموجب
قانون
القانون تبنته تبنته تبناه
بعض القوات المسلحه مظله شريك للقوات
المسلحه في كل العمليات العسكريه نحن قوه
سياسيه ما عندنا سبب في في وجود الدعم
السريع ووجود جيشين وجود منظومه عسكريه
اخرى
هناك سؤال بما انه عام 2017 صدر هذا
القانون واصبح الدعم السريع من ضمن الجيش
لماذا الان
بموضوع الاتفاق الاطاري هناك خلاف على
موضوع دمج يعني اصلا كلمه دمج هل هي سليمه
او صحيحه لتطلق على الدعم السريع بما انه
هو جزء من هذه المنظومه الامنيه العسكريه
العنوان العنوان العنوان الكبير العنوان
الفكري المؤسس الكبير نحن قلنا الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري الاصلاح العسكري والامني
والاصلاح ده بيشمل منظومه القوات المسلحه
وبيشمل دمج الدعم السريع في القوات
المسلحه
والطرفين الطرفين وقعوا على
الاتفاق الايطالي بهذا البروسيس السياسي
الذي حدث الذي حدث انا في تقديري
لتفادي نتائج العمليه السياسيه التي مخطط
لها ان تفضي الى سلطه مدنيه يعني يريدون
يعني
انت برايك الطرفان لا يريدان هذا الاتفاق
ولا يريدان الانتقال السياسي الى المدني
لا يريدان الانتقال السياسي والتعول
الديمقراطي لا يوجد ان ابقى معي ولكن نريد
ايضا ان نطلع على الامور على الارض ووضع
الجرحى وبالنسبه للضحايا من الخرطوم ينضم
اليه دكتور علاء الدين عوض عضو لجنه
الاستشاريين طبيه في السودان دكتور اهلا
بكم معنا هل يمكن ان تعطينا حصيله الضحايا
والجرحى وما هو وضع الجرح الان
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
شكرا على الصداقه ان شاء الله ربنا يزيل
الامه ويوقف هذه الحرب والله حقيقي الان
احصائيات يعني محدده اذا حتى الان صعب
الحديث لانه عدم القرحه
وحتى الاكثر الطبيه يعني صعب الحركه في
خلال الخرطوم عشان تصل مهمات
المعتقد انه في وفاتين وفي في جرحى في
مستشفى بشاير وفي مستشفى الاربعين حتى في
شرق لكن يعني لغايه ممكن تطلع احصائيات
سواء كان من اللجنه المثاليه او من من
احد الان عدد معين من الموضوع لكن
هناك حديث عن ثلاثه
سقطوا ولكن هل هناك هل هذا العدد دقيق
ماذا ايضا عن الضحايا من الاطراف
المتصارعه من الدعم السريع ومن الجيش هل
هناك اي معلومات حولها
والله حتى الان لا طبعا لانه بيمشي على
السلاح الطبي
عشان كده العسكريه معي كان ما ما
يعني لكن
حوالي خمسه عسكريين
لكن ما تقدر حتى الان نحن
الاحصائيات في اخر اليوم حتى كان في في
ايام المظاهرات دائما المنظر الاحصائيات
اخر اليوم الى كان في في يعني شهداء او او
استشهدين الوضع الامني هل يسمح بنقل
الجرحى او الضحايا الى المستشفيات ماذا
يمكن ان تخبرنا عن هذا الموضوع
حركه عربات الازعاج صعبه
في ظل الحاصل بين حتى الان نتحدث معاكم
وحوالين ما في صوت ذخيره وصافي يعني
[موسيقى]
تقريبا قريب يعني
حاليا
شكرا لك من الخرطوم دكتور علاء الدين عوض
عضو لجنه الاستشاريين الطبيه في السودان
طبعا مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع كل هذه الصور
التي نراها على شاشه العربيه للاشتباكات
الحاصله في السودان ان كانت في الخرطوم او
في مروي وبعض الولايات في السودان على كل
حال ايضا نتوقف مع بعض المواقف
للدول حول هذا التطور في السودان حيث دعا
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن
جميع الجهات الفاعله في السودان لوقف
العنف فورا وتجنب المزيد من التصعيد
ومواصله المفاوضات لحل القضايا العليقه
كما عبر عن بالغي قلقه ازاء تصاعد العنف
بين القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع
بريطانيا ايضا كان لها موقف حيث حثت
السفاره البريطانيه في السودان رعاياها
بالبقاء في اماكن مغلقه وقالت انها تراقب
الموقف عن كثب بعدما اعلنت قوات الدعم
السريع انها سيطرت على القصر الرئاسي وعلى
مواقع اخرى
طبعا مع تواصل هذه الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريه اكد الاتحاد
الافريقي لقناه العربيه انه يتابع عن كثب
وبقلق شديد تطورات الحاصله في السودان كما
حتى الاطراف السياسيه والعسكريه على ايجاد
حل سياسي منصف للازمه مشيرا الى انه يناشد
القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع الى الايقاف
الفوري لتدمير البلاد وتربيع سكانها وسفك
الدماء وداع الاتحاد الافريقي مكونات
المجتمع الدولي الى مضاعفه الجهود بشكل
موحد وعاجل
ايضا في الداخل السوداني كان هناك مواقف
لحزب الامه القوميه السوداني حيث دعا
الجيش وقوات الدعم الى الوقف الفوري
لاطلاق النار وعوده القوات الى مواقعها
السابقه التي كانت متمركزه فيها قبل
الاشتباكات وقال الحزب في بيانه انه يدعو
ايضا الى تكوين لجنه مشتركه من القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع وشخصيات قوميه
للاتفاق حول التهدئه ومنع حدوث فيلتات
امنيه كما شدد على ضروره عوده كل الاطراف
الى طاوله الحوار لحسم القضايا الخلافيه
لاكمال العمليه السياسيه ومنع اي شكل من
اشكال التدخل الاجنبي في البلاد
ايضا تجمع المهنيين السودانيين حمل قيادات
الجيش والدعم السريع اي خسائر بين
المدنيين تنجم عن هذه الاشتباكات الجاريه
بينهما ورجح تجمع المهنيين ان تمتد
الاشتباكات
ومحاولاته فرض السيطره بشكل واسع وخطير
مشيرا الى ان ما يدور الان هو جريمه اخرى
من جرائم النظام العسكري ونتاج طبيعي لسير
الاحداث وفق تعبيره وادعى التجمع الى
انشاء لجان المقاومه لحمايه الاحياء وحتى
المواطنين على العوده الى منازلهم وعدم
الانخراط في اي اعمال عدوانيه
[موسيقى]
ايضا مقطع فيديو اظهر طبعا تم تداوله عبر
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي لها اظهر دخول
قوات الدعم السريع وسيطرتها ايضا على
قياده اللواء الاول مشاه للقوات البريه
السودانيه نتابع
من قياده اللواء الاول انشاء الي للقوات
البريه
يا جماعه دي القياده كامله
في قبضتنا تماما تمام
واديك كروزراتهم وشايفلنا جاي لكم
الدبابات
نقدمه بيقولوها
دبابات دبابات سودانيه
الحمد لله الرجال اشتغلوا يا جماعه ابشروا
بالخير ابشروا بالخير رياده اللواء الاول
مشاه الي قوات البريه في فاتيلنا وطبعا
تتوالى مقاطع الفيديو حيث اظهر ايضا مقطع
فيديو على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي قوات
الدعم السريع الان داخل قاعده جبل اولياء
الجويه جنوب الخرطوم الله اكبر الله اكبر
جاهزين يا صراع
هزنا المطار بتاع جبل
الجويه بتاع الجبل
الطيارات الدبابات كلها
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الان من داخل قاعده النجوم الجويه تم
تحرير بالكامل ان شاء الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
والرئيس الان الرئيس الله اكبر
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
وزير خارجيه بريطانيا يتحدث بل يدعو ايضا
القياده السودانيه لبذل كل ما يمكن لكبح
قواتها ووقف التصصيد اذا هذا الموقف عبر
وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه ندعو القياده
السودانيه لبذل كل ما يمكن لذبح قواتها
ووقف التصعيد اعود اليك
المعتصم الكاتب الصحفي انت معي من الخرطوم
هناك عده مواقف يعني مالك عقار عضو مجلس
السياده السوداني كان يتحدث بان هذا العنف
اسباب منها سياسي ومنها اقتصادي ما
المقصود بذلك
السيد مالك عقار كان ضمن وفد الوساطه التي
اجتمعت خلال الايام الماضيه والى اول امس
مع الطرفين في محاوله لتكسير المواقف
ضمن مجموعه سياسيه ومجموعات اخرى ولكن
سياسيا يقصد بان الاتفاق السياسي
المزمع توقيعه كان ينهي وجود
المؤسسات العسكريه يرجع الجيش الى السكنات
ربما بعض
الاطراف من المكونات ترى انها لديها طموح
بتحكم السودان او لتصبح على
مكونات عسكريه نعم ومن الواضح هذا الامر
من الواضح هذا الامر ثم ثم ايضا اقتصاديا
هناك شبكه من المصالح التجاريه
والاقتصاديه لقوات الدعم السريع
سواء في الذهب وانت كثير من
الانشطه الاقتصاديه
مؤكد ان حمايتها
تجعل
الدعم السريعي يبحث عن مصالحه
ويحافظ عليها ولكن السؤال الاكبر استاذ
طاهر وهذا التخوف الاكبر عند كل المراقبين
وهذا التخوف ايضا من قبل كانت الدول
الاقليميه او المجتمع الدولي وهو امد هذه
هذا التصعيد يعني البعض يتحدث عن حرب
طويله الامد البعض يتخوف من حرب اهليه هل
الدعم السريع لديه القدره العسكريه
والعتاد والاسلحه ليواجه فيها
الجيش السوداني
استراتيجيه وعلى المدى الطويل يصعب جدا
على الدعم السريع او اي قوه اخرى ان تناسب
الجيش السوداني
العداء المؤسسه العسكريه السودانيه سنكون
يعني استنزاف للطرفين سنكون امام هذا
المشهد
ربما لكن المؤسسه العسكريه السودانيه
عمرها اكثر من 100 عام وحاربت في كثير من
الاوقات في جنوب السودان وفي غيرها
وحروب الاستنزاف
وتملك المغضره على حزم المعارك ولكن
النجاح في معركه واحده لا يعني ان الح
ربه يمكن ان تتمدد يمكن ان تخرج الى يمكن
ان تصبح في اماكن اخرى
ايضا الجيش السوداني مثلا الان هناك عجل
على العربيه وايضا ثلاث ساعات الماضيه كان
هناك حديث عن انضمام بعض المجموعات من
الدعم السريع والعوده الى الجيش الان هذا
العجل يتحدث عن مجموعه من المتقاعدين الى
اي حد من الممكن ان يخسر
الدعم السريع بعض من افراد في صفوفه
فيخسر الكثير سيخسر الكثير جدا جدا ليس
البعض بل الكثير
المؤسسه القوات المسلحه السودانيه بغض
النظر عن اختلاف البعض معها او
اتفاق مع غيادته في انها ترخص فيها ان
تكون في السلطه هي مؤسسه عريقه وذاته
تغاليد وذاتا تغذيرات
واسس علميه وخطط ممنهجه بالتالي من
الصعوبه بما كان ان تستطيع قوات الدعم
السريع عن تغيير في وجه الجيش السوداني
طبعا
الجيش السوداني جيش عريق مؤسسه يعني
ظلت راسخه
تقدم تجاربها حتى للدول
العربيه ولا افريقيه يعني مؤسسه الجيش
مؤسسه يعني ما في زول بيتكلم عن الضعفه
لكن
الدعم السريع طبعا قوه
رشيقه يعني قوه سريعه الحركه
واوجد الجيش من الايام لمحاربه الحركات
المسلحه يعني حتى الدعم السريع تدريب
وتاهيل وبعدين بعض الكوادر من القوات
المسلحه ظلت ترفض الدعم السريع بخبرتها
ظلت تشغل وظائف عليا في الدعم السريع يعني
هناك صعوبه هناك صعوبه من الغاء
السريع او او
الغاء او ابعاد السيد حميتي عن قياده
الدعم السريع فاذا الحل اين يكمن يعني لا
الجيش لا دعم السريع قادر ان يواجه الجيش
على المدى الطويل والجيش ايضا الدعم
السريع هو فصيل من فصائل الجيش الى حد ما
وخاصه بعد قانون عام 2017
تكلفات كبيره بالنسبه للشعب السوداني
تكلفته كبيره بالنسبه لهذا الوطن
الجريحه الذي ظل يتوقى الى الحريه
والديمقراطيه انا افتكر
انه رغم تامين على قوه الجيش لكن صعب صعب
[موسيقى]
بالمنتصر
المنتصر دائما سيكون هناك منتصر ام سنصل
الى وقت لا غالب ولا مغلوب وبالتالي تكون
كل ما حصل دفع ثمنه بعض المدنيين وبعض
الافراد العسكريين تحت عمره قيادات
تتخانق مع بعضها
انا افتكر انا افتكر يعني
حيكون هناك منتصر لكن هذا المنتصر هو
رغمي انتصار هو الخاسر لانه
بنى انتصاره على دماء على تدمير الدوله
على تكلفه عاليه ونحن في مرحله نحتاج
لوفاق سياسي نحن كقوه سياسيه ظلينا منا
منذ الامس ما عندنا تصنيفات ما عندنا عداء
للطرفين الطرفين من ابناء السودان الطرفين
مهمات في التحول الديمقراطي مهمات مهمات
في العمليه السياسيه ولذلك في مبادره
شغالين في في مبادره حساسه مدعومه باراده
سودانيه لوقف لوقف الخطاب ما هي نسبه نجاح
هذه المبادره هل من مؤشرات يعني في ظل
اصوات البنادق والاسلحه
المتوسطه والخفيفه والثقيله ايضا هل هناك
من مؤشرات على انه هذه المبادره من الممكن
ان يكون او يكتب لها النجاح
انا انا ثقتي ثقتي كبيره في قائد الجيش
وغير قائد الدعم السريه نحن سودانيين
بنغضب كده ونتحامك كذا لكن يعني
هناك فرق هناك هناك قصف هناك مدنيين هناك
دوله البعض يتخوف من ان لا يبقى دوله في
في السودان
سماحه الشخصيه السودانيه انا متفق معاك
انا متفق معاكي في التحليل المنطقي به لكن
هناك في شخصيه سودانيه رغم الغضب ورغم
الثوره سماحه كده يجب ان يقدر
يعني تكلفه الحرب وارواح السودانيين من كل
من كل الطرف من من الطرفين انا يعني عندي
امل
حقيقه بديه ويعني اظن بانه الكل يتساءله
اذا كنا سنصل الى مرحله لا غالب ولا مغلوب
ويعود سيد حميتي والسيد عبد الفتاح
البرهان ويجلس على نفس الطاوله لماذا هذا
التصعيد الان
الاختلاف السياسي عندهم قتال
الاختلاف السياسي عندهم حروب
لذلك يعني برايك
الاطار الاتفاق ايضا هل سيظل موجود الالنت
تؤثر كل هذه الاشتباكات وكل هذا التصعيد
على الحل السياسي على الاتفاق السياسي
عطلوا مسار الثوره السودانيه في التحول
الديمقراطي يمكن حل السلمي وفي التوافق
السياسي لكن
حيظل على هذا الاتفاق السياسي هذه العمليه
السياسيه هتظل العمليه السياسيه الخيار
الوحيد انا قبل يومين صرحته قلت عمليه
سياسيه الحاليه للحرب
اتمنى اتمنى ان يعود الطرفين للعمليه
السياسيه شكرا لك من الخرطوم دكتور كمال
عمر الامين السياسي لحزب المؤتمر الشعبي
وعضو اللجنه التنسيقيه للحوار الايطالي
كما اشكر ايضا استاذ طاهر المعتصم الكاتب
الصحفي كنت معي من الخرطوم
ايضا اظهرت لقطات فيديو متداوله مواجهات
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
شبه العسكريه في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم نتابع بعضها
[موسيقى]
لا حول ولا قوه
الدعم السريه تقول انها اغلقت منافذ جنوب
الخرطوم ايضا هناك صور متداوله لاشتباكات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع بالقرب من
المدينه الرياضيه جنوب العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم نتابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الان ينضم الي من القاهره السفير حسام زكي
الامين العام المساعد لجامعه الدول
العربيه سعاده السفير اهلا بك معنا اذا
اردنا ان نعلق على ما يجري في السودان وما
هي الجهود
لوقف هذا العنف الحاصل بين الاطراف
العسكريه في السودان
اهلا بحضرتك طبعا هذا الموقف مؤسس للغايه
وصدر عن عن الجماعه صباح اليوم طبعا
رد فعل
يعني ينشد الاطراف بوقف التصعيد وحقن
الدماء واعلنا ان هناك استعداد من جانب
الامانه العامه للتدخل في هذا الامر اذا
وافق الطرفان
لاستعاده الهدوء طبعا
موافقه من الطرفين ام لا جواب حتى الان
يعني اكون صريح معك هذه المناشده اصدرناها
عبر الاعلام التواصل الان تواصل صعب
للغايه يعني يصعب انه يحصل تواصل اللي هو
التواصل المعتاد
للقيادات في الطرفين لكن المناشده
اصدرناها اعلاميا لعلها تصل الى الاخوه في
الجانبين ويعلق عليها ولكن ما يهمني هنا
ان اشدد عليه هو
ضروره وضع مصلحه السودان في المقام الاول
المساله
لا تتعلق
بالقوات المسلحه فقط ولا قوات الدعم
السريع فقط هناك دوله السودان التي يعني
الجميع يريدها والجميع يريد ان تحافظ على
وحدتها وسيادتها واستقلالها
والكل يرغب في ان يرى هذه الدوله على
المسار الصحيح ما يحدث الان لا يضعها على
المسار الصحيح بل على العكس وهو يعني يهدد
وحده هذا البلد
ويضع عرقيل كثيره جدا امام اعاده تكوينه
لمستقبله الذي كنا جميعا نستبشر به خيرا
لي انكم جاه
زون مبادره جاهزه لدى جامعه الدول العربيه
لتطرحها على الاطراف المتصارعه وهل من
ضمانات ممكن ان تقدموها حتى يتوقف هذا
العنف الان
من المبكر الحديث عن
شيء جاهز يطرح على الاطراف من المبكره
الحديث عن هذه المطلوب الان هو تجميد
الموقف ووقف التصعيد لانه استمرار التصعيد
يذهب بنا الى مرحله من الحرب ربما تاخذ
يعني وقتا طويلا والجميع فيها خاسر لن
يكون فيها اطراف يعني منتصره المنتصر فيها
مهزوم
فالامل هنا هو وقف التصعيد اما الحل
الامثل وطويل الاجل والذي يعطي الاستقرار
للدوله السودانيه فهذا امر
سبق ان بحثه السودانيون ومستعدون ايضا
للمساعده في هذا الامر لانه امر مرتبط
بالوضع السياسي العام ومرتبط بالقوى
المدنيه السياسيه المشاركه في السياسيه
فهذا امر له ارتباطات عديده
نسعى الان الى هدف محدد وهو وقف التصعيد
ووقف اطلاق النار والعوده بالامور الى
مرحله من الهدوء ساعات السفير قلت بانه من
الصعوبه الان التحدث الى الاطراف
المتصارعه ولكن هل يتم الحديث او هل يتم
الاتصال ببعض الاحزاب المتواجده داخل
السودان والفاعله والتي حقيقه ايضا تقوم
بتقديم مبادرات وتناشد بوقف هذا العنف
شوفي حضرتك الجميع في داخليا وخارجيا
اعتقد انه يقف في نفس النقطه وهو ان الكل
يناسب الكل يناشد هناك الان
اليات عسكريه على الارض جنود مشتبكين مع
بعضهم البعض
في طيران بيستخدم في
دبابات على الارض في الخرطوم وخارج
الخرطوم وفي مدن اخرى هذا واضح في منتهى
منتهى
الصعوبه والدقه
ومرشح لان يستمر ويتدهور ونحن نهدف الى
الحيلوله دون ذلك كل الاخوه السودانيين
ولعلهم معاكم في الاعلام كمان الجميع
يناشد والجميع
يحاول ان يوصل صوته الى القيادات لكن طبعا
هذه المساله مساله دقيقه وصعبه
ولن تتم
بشكل بشكل سريع ولكن لا نفقد الامل ونظل
نحاول ان نطالب الطرفين بشتى الطرق سواء
بطرق مباشره او طرق غير مباشره منها مثلا
عن طريق الاعلان انه الاطراف
تتراجع او
تجمد من يعني نشاطها العسكري حتى لا يتسبب
التصعيد في المزيد من التصعيد وبالتالي
تصل الامور الى ما لا تحمد عقبه اشكرك
سعاده السفير حسام زكي الامين العام
المساعد لجامعه الدول العربيه ونامل طبعا
هذه المناشده التي اطلقتها عبر شاشه
العربيه نامل ان تلقى اذاننا صاغيه وايضا
تسبب وقف هذا العنف المتصاعد داخل السودان
شكرا لك
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع هذه التطورات
على الساحه السودانيه
سنعود لنذكر ببعض العواجل على شاشه
العربيه مصادر عسكريه العربيه تتحدث عن ان
الجيش السوداني تمكن من السيطره على اغلب
المرافق في مطار مروي ايضا كان هناك دعوات
من الدول العربيه
وعلى راسها الخارجيه السعوديه التي دعت
ايضا الى وقف هذا العنف وناشدت الاشقاء في
السودان لوقف الاقتتال بالاضافه الى ايضا
الان
ممثل عن الامين العام للجامعه العربيه
ساعات السفير قال وناشد وقال بانهم هم
مستعدون لاي وساطه بين الاطراف وحتى يت
وقف هذا العنف ايضا هناك بعض المصادر
العسكريه للعربيه تحدثت بان الجيش
السوداني تمكن من ضرب اغلب مراكز التواصل
للدعم السريع هذه التغطيه مستمره على شاشه
العربيه نتابعها بعد لحظات مع زميله ميسون
عزام